we're very happy to have Paul Krassner
with us today on alternative views Paul
resin is a legend both during and after
his time Paul's time was the 1960s when
his unique political journal the realist
contains some of the most advanced
political satire and comedy of the day
Paul was also one of the founders of the
hippies an a narco absurdist group that
got national attention in the 1960s well
yuppies became yuppies but Paul Krassner
lives on Paul once again began
publishing the realist in 1984 and
recently published issue number 104
Paul has also been traveling around the
country doing his unique political
comedy routine and is standing out once
again is one of our most distant police
with Paul Krassner we will interspersed
sections of an interview with your
friend of ours robert wilkinson did with
paul his interview is in quite a
different format from ours and covers
different subjects but before we talk
with Paul Krassner and find out what's
going and the wacky world of political
and social satire here are some news
stories first real scandal the Bush
administration was not really addressed
in the mainstream media and that is this
tremendous 166 billion dollar bailout
for the Savings & Loan industry during
the deregulation of the Reagan
administration when banks savings and
loans as much as the Reagan
administration could deregulate was
deregulated the Savings and Loan
industry went into an orgy of bad
investments of wasting money on all
kinds of investments or boats for their
executives or parties or orgies or
whatever and some hundreds of savings
and loans administration's have gone out
of business have gone down the tubes in
the federal government and the US
taxpayer has been called in to bail them
out so we're in this tremendous deficit
situation all kinds of programs are
being cut social programs
and yet the US government is giving 166
billion dollars to savings alone for a
rescue operation and economists like in
the London economists say that it could
be as much as three hundred billion
dollars to rescue the savings and loan
now it's very interesting what the other
options to deal with the Savings and
Loan problem could have been and how
they weren't reported by the mainstream
media for instance the representative
from Massachusetts Joseph Kennedy jr.
and another representative Bruce
Morrison proposed a very rational
project program to help deal with the
savings and loan problems they proposed
to specific taxes to pay for all of the
savings and loans that were going out of
business and to ensure people's money in
which people that were making over
$250,000 a year would pay a small tax to
help the savings and loans out and there
would be a corporate profit tax that
would also help pay off the savings and
loan project this is perfectly fair and
reasonable Kennedy and Morrison said
because the people that really benefited
from the Reagan policies from the high
interest rates in the savings and loans
during that era in the stock market
speculation that was connected with this
Savings and Loan speculation these
people are the ones that have benefited
some other ones that ought to pay
Kennedy said none of the people who
enjoyed the benefit of Learjets none of
the people who enjoyed the benefits of
brokered SNL deposits those aren't the
people who are going to be asked to bail
it out that are going to end up
subsidizing a lot of high flour flyers
and it seems the Democratic Party ought
to be willing to stand up and I think
the Congress in general ought to be
willing to stand up to some of the
powerful interests in this country of
course the Democrats in the Congress
weren't willing to stand up for it so
now according to calculation every
taxpaying individual in the United
States will have to
a one to four thousand dollars to help
finance the Savings and Loan bailout
rather than a corporate or high-income
tax that could have solved the same
problem and again the media has just not
touched this major scandal of the Bush
years well the banks are the biggest
stockholders and the networks and they
have people on the boards of directors
of the network so they're not going to
get into this the spotlight has had a
lot of articles on it they're
right-wingers but they're right-wing
populist that's why their opinions
they'll get on the regular media but
they've had a lot of articles on the S&L
bailout and they've quoted the
congressman Gonzales who's the chairman
of the house banking currency committee
because he himself says that this is
baloney what the Congress has actually
passed and he's been criticizing that
but of course he doesn't get on the
regular media either but he says and the
spotlight confirms that in these SNL's
over 60 percent of the cases that
absolute fraud has been involved more
than ten thousand cases of suspected
fraud self-dealing
corruption outright thievery by bank
executives have been tallied so far but
the really thing that really grinds you
is that in most cases these clowns who
drove these SNL's into the ground made
all kinds of money of it there are
allowing - they're being allowed to keep
all their ill-gotten gains
hundreds of fail savings banks and the
top managers will who responsible for
all that they'll continue to draw their
fat salaries and be paid after the
bailout begins and they even have what
they call in golden parachutes or some
kind of parachutes which allow them to
even if they're kicked out they still
will be able to draw enormous amounts of
money in the when I first came to Texas
in the 1973 I was looking frequently at
the Texas observer and they used to do
stories on banks and
almost the many many issues would show
where these rich guys will go down to a
small bank somewhere and they would
immediately start giving loans to
themselves and their buddies they break
the bank the bank go belly-up and they
go off and do it to another bank so it
isn't unusual the spotlight had gave an
example of what what this bailouts going
to do and how the guys who were
responsible for it are still going to
benefit they talk about a situation with
former chairman of the Democratic Party
Robert Strauss and his son Rick and
their friends they took over Gibraltar
savings and first Texas savings they had
a merger and then of course they got
involved just like all the rest of them
the thing went belly up
they moved aggressively into junk bonds
and real estate speculation and so the
way they went
now there was another guy involved with
him by the name of akin gump now he was
he was a leading Dallas law firm was
partner in it he which Robert Strauss
was a senior partner now akin gump was
appointed general counsel to the to this
to the banks that they had and they're
also Jay Livingston costs Berg was the
multi-millionaire Houston financier he
was involved in it too
so what did they do well most many of
the loans went to default but this
Strauss is profited because akin gump
through his law firm was reportedly
billing the bank of million dollars a
month for services legal services
providing for doing foreclosures the
same year Texas Gibraltar put up
whopping 135 million dollars to buy the
flying m branch ranch which was 6,300
square acre outfit from Dallas and that
land development company was owned by
Rick Strauss all in the family
he got a big lavish deal from the bank
you got a management contract for the
ranch at three million dollars annual
fee guarantee
read for 25 years and he stands to get
25 percent of any profits realized at
the time the ranches sold well cost BER
who we talked about a while ago he's got
a good deal for himself as chairman of
first Texas Gibraltar he arranged the
sale of the bank's entire data
processing system to a small company in
which he secretly was a major
shareholder and this goes on and on all
these insider trading switch they had
with each other so what happens well
Danny wall the chairman of the Federal
Home Loan Bank board which took over
first Texas Gibraltar allowed these guys
to run the bank into the ground who ran
the run the back here the graph he
allowed him to keep their private
bonanzas all these deals that work that
caused the thing to go under he's let
him keep it
an investigator says rock Robert Strauss
and his law firm are still general
counsel to Texas first Texas Gibraltar
Rick Strauss has kept his lavish
contract to run the flying em ranch the
only difference here is that his yearly
fee of 3 million is now being paid by
the taxpayers his old saying in Congress
that the bank's never lose and meanwhile
the SNL's are gone there you know is
finished and the regular banks have now
taken them over and the FS LIC is no
more so all of the reforms of the New
Deal years in which they were trying to
set up banks which would be used to help
common ordinary people to buy homes that
system is destroyed and being taken over
by the big guys back in Wall Street hmm
seriously enough Frank I saw pretty
in-depth CBS report on that Rick Straus
scandal well although they had more of a
development scandal that he was involved
in were a lot of the money he was
getting from his bank wheeling and
dealing he put into a development
project that turned out to be a lemon
and a lot of people lost a lot of
it seems the media is eager to expose
these scandals if they involve prominent
Democratic politicians obviously Robert
Strauss being Rick's father this shows
badly on him and of course Jim Wright
and some other Democratic congressman
had all of their financial dealings
exposed in great detail in the media so
the way the media seems to pursue these
kinds of stories is just as personal
scandal particularly ones that involve
political zet cetera they never really
go into the systemic structures that's
all the time we have for news right now
we'll have some more news later in the
program but now let's turn our attention
to our interviews with Paul Krassner
Paul is a social critic political
satirist and does incredible comedy
routines when he travels here and there
around the country he's also editor and
publisher of the realist which is well
you don't know if it's really satire or
whether it's reality but anyway we have
our two interviews one we did with him
and one which a friend of ours robert
wilkinson did so let's enjoy this first
of a two-part series with one of the
original yuppies well Paul were
extremely pleased to have you with us
today on alternative views and what we'd
like to do is to begin talking about the
iran-contra hearings and then go into
some of the history of the realist
yuppies and yuppies the 1960s what
you've been doing since then recently
you've been doing some commentary for
Pacifica Radio have you not on the
iran-contra hearings what's your general
sense of them been it's sort of like the
Marx Brothers with a political ideology
just very strange I mean the bottom line
for me is something that happened in
1984 people think that this because 1984
is past that it's finished with but
there was a press conference when a
reporter asked Ronald Reagan why are we
providing covert support to the so
called freedom fighters in Nicaragua and
Reagan answered because
it would be against the law to do it
overtly and and that has stayed with me
you know the implications of that it
explains you know it explains the
consistency if that that's the basic
premise so it just means that the law is
not something to follow so much as to
get around to continue doing what you
want to do and that kind of rationale I
think explains everything it explains
why lying has become our national
purpose because you need light to
support covert actions so what they
really so you know when you rip that the
shroud off of that sentence it's really
saying if it's not a law then we act to
get around it and so the pretense that
this is a nation of laws when it's
really a nation of control what's the
most glaring inconsistency in America
today I guess it's the pretense that we
care about people that the government
cares about people when the government
really cares about maintaining his own
power so it's frustrating to watch that
you know and it and it's horrifying to
see you know what it's like it's like
satirical prophecy Lenny Bruce had a bit
where he talked about a politician who
was a total crook but came out and
admitted it and people voted for him
because at least he was honest about it
and that's coming true now with North
right now they're so hard up for a hero
they're willing to take a psychopath
it's like a Bob and Ray routine the
corrupt mayor of skunk Haven New Jersey
he openly admits it all that's right
that's right if he can't be such a bad
guy if he admits to you know dropping
the typewriter ball or whatever he's
scraping it I mean it's it's really very
surrealistic I mean who could have
imagined that somebody would become a
hero because he was shredding documents
while the Justice Department was
investigating the same office I mean
it's so bizarre that I think the country
is kind of on a
a schizophrenic binge and you know
schizophrenic don't know this gets a
phrenic the in Watergate people who
destroyed evidence went to jail but here
they're heroes
it's strange well but but it's just
because everything's accelerating I mean
Colonel North is probably very
comparable to gee gordon liddy
and gee gordon liddy as a hero now but
since things are accelerating it's more
like fast food approach you get instant
heroism so you don't have to wait he
doesn't have you don't have to wait for
as he had to wait with Liddy before he
could you know become an actor on Miami
Vice and the participant in the password
with with Betty White holding his hand
and saying here's the man who thought of
assassinating Jack Anderson as a viable
option let's here a hat you know Oliver
North Side of assassinating all the
ayatollahs as a viable action that was
one of his plans that again has it come
out in the hearings has been published
in the national news services but no one
has asked him about his plot to
assassinate Iranian leaders just like C
cordon these people had a plot to
assassinate sandanista leaders even
before the Revolution there's little
bits of this that pop out though you
know because when they first asked when
Lyman first SC court about the Christic
lawsuit he said it was preposterous that
it was a fairy tale but then more
recently when Robinette testified the
CIA liaison he testified that he was
getting $4,000 a month from Secord to
investigate the journalist who had
instituted the LaPenta bombing lawsuit
and and of course he's a electronics
expert so Robinette may well have been
involved in you know because when he
says investigate them you can translate
that a smear you know explode
whatever we also saw a guy earlier on
I'm trying to remember his name who
testified that almost in passing that he
was there at the capture of Che Guevara
you know you could translate that
hillocks Rodriguez who goes back to the
Bay of Pigs that's right all kinds of
operation right so what happens is when
Felix Rodriguez codename max Gomez can
testify that he went to George Bush's
house I think to wish him happy birthday
something like that now we know that
preppy George is not about to have what
he obviously views as a [ __ ] come
to his house you know get off my lawn
you know unless you're going to stand in
front of the mailbox so it's just it's
just such obvious lying that it's it you
have to I think humor for me has been
like a what valium was to Robert
mcFarland you know it's just one way of
surviving the hearings or maybe Oliver
North he looks like he was more and more
tranquilized every day as the week went
on yet he was obviously an effective
witness for his cause why do you think
people responded to north favorably
style you know I think it's SS fron Hall
said she represented the American public
when she said I do not retain substance
and so it's his style is is kind of
somewhere between James Stewart and mr.
Smith goes to Washington and Tony
Perkins and psycho you know and so they
can't quite pinpoint it but they but
they realized that there is this he's
already been pre digested by the media
in his terms of his prototype we've seen
these ally for Ally and 88 or Ollie 488
buttons is that way along with his
medals you mean they're know people want
running for president and all that
I know but guys and they don't even care
that he never changes his clothes you
know shows what an understanding public
there is what so even worse is that they
they're completely they're using these
hearings to as a medium for son and ista
bashing and there's no no real no truth
they have coming out about what the son
of nieces revolution is about and what
the society is really absolutely
lies and yet they're getting away with
it by the media turning it into
propaganda if they if they have that
slideshow that they gave to the
supporters you know it's just so
outrageous that I have to take a walk
and think okay this is really happening
you know these guys are really and it's
what they all have in common is they're
afraid for their jobs nobody wants to
lose a job that's why they follow orders
and it includes the journalists they're
the photographer's we have to keep
clicking
every time that the lawyer Sullivan
whispers into the ear of Colonel north
they get a shot of it you know maybe
they'll get something more different
pose this time maybe we'll see the
tongue in the year you know get on the
cover of The National Enquirer hustler
maybe yeah so but they want to keep
their jobs the senators want to keep
their jobs so they won't criticize North
even if they feel critical of him
because they're afraid of what the
constituency so it's like everybody's
operating on fear the whole media
operate on fear anyway you know
especially the commercial media where
they instill fear and you you know of
how your armpits smell how you false
teeth are going to fall out when you're
performing a bank robbery you know I
mean it's how your crotch is going to
drive people away you know that if a
Martian came to earth and watch the
media they would think that this culture
is fueled on fear well this is whole the
whole appeal of North is fear of
communism fear that there's going to be
a domino effect in Central America and
they're going to come charging over the
Texas border and take away the
television sets and video recorders
that's right the only difference between
bernard goetz
and oliver north is that oliver north
has a uniform and but you know is they
share the same clinical paranoia they're
not guests just was afraid of four guys
in the subway and north is afraid of the
entire sandanista government although
there's more grounds for fear in urban
you know disintegrating urban context of
crime that's a rational fear than the
fear of communism particularly of the
Nicaraguans
who posit no rational threat but anyone
but yet people are really afraid but
that's the thing about a psychopath
they it's it had they have their own
logic you know I mean so you can get
somebody who's you know I'm hearing
Johnny Carson through my teeth I mean
that's a reality to them and you could
say well we'll go to a dentist and he'll
take care of us you know the dentist is
in on it because they they have to have
a logic to fit their basic original
premise and even if they got a dentist
he could trust to pull out of all of his
teeth you know he'd say I hear Johnny
Carson through my gums now this America
need to look at and really whiten up
about um a high tech and low sodium I
think would fit the bill America really
itself first of all you know our own
power and how we have used it without
compassion sometimes I mean it's
something to laugh about and cry about
alter ultimately yeah and our own
tendency to try and reshape history I'll
give you a specific example they've been
sort of a media campaign to separate
those who protest at the Vietnam War
from those who fought the Vietnam War
and it's a false dichotomy because our
slogan always was bring the boys back
home you know it wasn't slaughter them
and so it's appropriate that country Joe
McDonald just organized that Vietnam
Veterans Film Festival and he had been a
lot of anti-war rallies but as he says
we were against the war not the Warriors
and so yeah that's just a subdivision of
general mythology it can pick any
subject in this probably a myth about it
having mythos as good as a mile stop
that
well how do you deal with the Contras in
your comedy routines or your political
satire well I you know I try to talk
about foreign hauls dating the son of
the contour leader and try to imagine
you know the pillow-talk now i destroyed
another village today honey ah you know
let's practice safe sex oh and be sure
to wear contraceptives I have joke Lexia
I can't help it right well actually the
Contras are difficult phenomena to make
jokes about because of all the terrorist
activity because of all the casual
killing they do in Nicaragua I mean this
is not funny and it's a difficult topic
well as a matter of fact the cover of
the current issue of the realist has a
cartoon by Nicole Hollander who does the
Silvius trip right and she's very
political and a strong feminist and
comes from a union family and is because
it's a perfect example of the trivedi
trivialization of tragedy really yes as
and now mrs. Jones for the dishwasher
and the matching Ottoman can you name
the group sometimes call the moral
equivalent of the founding fathers who
is profited from smuggling plane loads
of coke into the United States and she's
saying hmm because the attention span is
that you know it so symptoms um yeah
what about a Ronald Reagan he must be
great subject for any oh yeah yeah he's
his wallowing in Teflon now and
knee-deep up to his belly button already
and but when I you know Paula Pollock
political poisoning begins in a home I
heard that if you scratch Teflon there's
poison that seeps through and so that's
happening on a metaphorical level with
Reagan but when I learned that I threw
away my frying pan which had scratch it
and rivers at every time cooking
something in it you know I'm getting the
poison underneath so that it
really does beginning you know with your
own private relations the politics and
then expands into national and
international scenes I mean this is why
the hypocrisy over Gary Hart was you
know Americans aren't that concerned
about adultery but they had to they had
to go through the motions and do what I
call the Elliott Abrams School of lying
you know so he never said is he lying
you say I misspoke testimony or as out
of a North says it wasn't lie it was
just what was the phrase he used
plausible deniability right that's
they're eligible or you can lie you can
call somebody else a liar without using
the way you just say his memory
difference from my memory
and so in terms of deliberately
misleading that's what Gary Hart was
doing you know saying well no there was
a side door and then as his wife got
sucked into that line you know if Gary
says nothing happened and nothing
happened and you know when they were
home it was different you know honey
would you get me a beer just let that
blonde bimbo get you your beer is
America in your opinion so hung up on
banning four-letter words since most
people do them you know the F word the S
word you know and so forth the American
up well I don't know if it's fair to say
America is hung up on it the FCC is hung
up on us
I mean Lenny Bruce got arrested in 1962
for saying [ __ ] on stage in San
Francisco ten letter words right right
beginning with C and then you're
intelligent viewers can figure it out
like a crossword puzzle and 20 years
later Meryl Streep got an Academy Award
for saying the same word and in Sophie's
Choice and if she didn't get it then
Francis would have gotten it and
and Jessica Lange would have gotten for
saying the same word in Francis so the
taboos have changed you know and but the
FCC of course is just using the language
as an excuse to attack a station like
KPFK in Los Angeles for political
reasons you have to but you can set a
precedent like that and it's easy to set
a precedent with so-called obscenity but
it's all arbitrary you know so I can't
go on a Pacifica station now and talk
about finger because even though I mean
it as a noun the FCC will insist that I
meant it as a verb so it's just a matter
of translation I could I can go on the
media and like to come yeah Lenny Bruce
is bit to come it's a fallout of word
war even the word dick now you can use
dick if it's a person's proper name you
know I can go on the media and sing my
boy dick but I can't go on and talk
about my dick boy to end it what's the
difference just the capital letter it's
a capital punishment issue okay this is
a psychology of the thing you know what
is it what is it four little words are
an easy target you know then and a good
subterfuge they're not going to say
we're attacking you because KPFK is
running the entire hearings with good
commentary by Larry Ben ski in
Washington and he interviews people from
the Christic Institute all who have the
lawsuit who exposed the secret team that
does assassinations and gun-running and
drug running so they can obviously say
that's the reason so in any society they
always go after the sexuality first
because it's a cover for going after the
political and ultimately you can't
separate the sexual from the political
maybe a bundling board well I've always
been wanting to ask you why you call
your political journal the realist it
sounds like surrealism or if you read
the stories in it or hear the kinds of
stories you're telling now why do you
call this the realist well I suppose in
a certain sense that that the title is
the most ethereal thing about the
magazine but I think I think it is you
know
the realism for me is kind of trying to
maintain a balance between cynicism and
optimism and and so that's reality for
everybody I mean the big thing of course
about reality is that it's totally
subjective and so that everybody who
reads the realist you know reads it
through the filter of their own
experience and projections and I know
that and so when I meet people
especially when they have say seeing the
book the best of the realist which was
the collection an anthology of sixteen
years and they'll say you know this
particular cartoon or this particular
article and it's like a projective test
it's like a Rorschach because I reveal
more about them than it does about the
realist well it seems to me that our
politics and our politicians in the
United States in the two decades or so
that you've been doing the realist in
your political humor lend themselves to
satire they're so absurd ridiculous and
surrealistic
in and of themselves that only satire in
some sense can catch the absurd truth oh
yes because it's because they try to
master the illusion of sincerity that's
why Colonel north is so good I mean he
reeks with sincerity and and so the the
satire is just almost something I'm
holding up the mirror to what they
actually say not even exaggerating I
mean Ronald Reagan actually said in 1980
if I am elected I will end the
inheritance tax for rich and poor alike
now where can I take that you know if I
report that the people they haven't seen
it in the paper they think I made it up
already you know you just get the the
the image of some wino singer and I
bequeath my entire six pack of ripple to
my daughter you know it's it or the time
that John Hinckley shot the president
and Hinckley came out for gun control
and Reagan came out against it no so who
you know who's the schizo Reagan himself
you know the man is the you hear all
these people say well is he is he
psychotic is he is he crazy as a senile
or is the extremely shrewd or is
just the consumer actors so that who has
lost the line between reality and script
well it's just it's just the government
by public relations you know you could
you could see when there was the first
black Miss America he called her up when
the hockey team won he called them up
you know it's always he got who would
ever have thought that the president
would be photographed with Michael
Jackson
you know this black kid with curly
greasy here is an androgynous right and
wears a white glove and sings in a high
voice and it was John right so he could
look like Diana Ross and yet and wants
to buy the remains of the Elephant Man
you know I mean so this surrealistic
thing but you know there are Michael
Jackson fans who vote and so it's all
thought of as constituency so it's all
government by public relations when
Dennis Wilson of the Beach Boys drowned
in the Pacific Ronald Reagan granted
special President presidential
permission for him to be buried at sea I
mean big deal he could have just left
them there but you know they wanted to
get the Beach Boys fan to vote what do
you love about America what don't you
love
I don't know I'm torn between the
Rockets red glare by the dawn's early
light or the twilight's last gleaming I
can't decide what do I say that again
what do I like best real love about
America and what don't you love actually
they're they're they're related it's a
paradox what what I love the least is
that people have come into power in this
country by a series of political
assassinations that then made it look as
if they were a mandate for the remaining
candidates and what I love most about
America is that I have the freedom to
say how rotten we are it's a paradox a
paradox and three geese it's a full
house where you got
I've saw a newspaper article where
quoted you as saying social commentary
is now taboo assuming that was a correct
quote yeah and actually I was quoting
when I started they had been an eleven
year hiatus when I stopped publishing
the realist as a magazine and started
again as a newsletter and I did a lot of
media research and talked to people and
it was a TV producer who had said that
to me actually a network producer said
well you know we can we maybe not use
the language to say the cable could use
but we can deal with the concepts you
know incest abortion euthanasia we can
do it but in terms of humor he said
social commentary itself has become the
taboo and I think that's kind of the
trend in comedians you know they they
talk about certain you know they'll talk
cute stuff about Jim and Tammy Bakker
they'll talk about the makeup you know
and and get into that but it is literate
literally and figuratively superficial
you know I mean when I talk about the
new right I'll talk about Pat Robertson
and the fact that there are these layers
of scandal you know he can be sucked
into the vacuum created by the PTL the
700 club club kind of gets tarnished
with that same scandal but it ignores
the covert action information bulletin
has his picture on the cover reviewing
the contra troops and the CBN the
Christian Broadcasting Network has been
funneling aid to the Contras and Oliver
North has met with people from the 700
club I mean the White House was filled
with a bunch of Armageddon born-agains
between Ronald Reagan and ed Meese who
has said that he wants the White House
and the the National Security Council to
be exorcised from demons all over North
another born-again weirdos of Oliver
North definitely as for a Weinberger
yeah and these people these people it's
it's why there could almost be an
organization anti-semites for Israel
because that they are anti submitting
but the pro-israel because they won all
the Jews to be there when Armageddon
strikes in the form of the nuclear
holocaust and and so and they feel
everybody will be caught up who's good
by their standard will be caught up in
the rapture and so they really have no
sense as an other culture if you know if
we pass this law what will it do for
generations seven generations from now
they have no it's like the EM they have
an MTV attention span
well James Watt was saying that's why
should we protect the forests and the
wilderness because the the world's going
to be destroyed that's right hands full
or two years that's really why they had
to let him go because he was that
blatant about it I mean he's an another
example of government by public
relations here was a guy the truth was
that he did a joke that was embarrassing
to the administration but they try to
make it look like a virtue when he left
you know he said well I came to the
Department of the Interior and my job is
done I'd like to spend some more time
with my wife I live with a wonderful
woman a black to Jews and a [ __ ] he
didn't say that but it was between the
lines do you change or adds new cabinet
positions what would they be
secretary boy well I think the cabinet
should be over there near the mirror and
I think the sofa would go over here did
I go to the bathroom I think the toilet
should be on the left side near the
window and the bathtub I think at a kind
of catty-corner angle the cabinet who
would I change well and I think well I
think we would make George Shultz the
Secretary of doormat because he's
willing to be stepped all over now as
long as he can keep his job anyway I
would make Allen Ginsberg the secretary
of Paula tree and pederasty I think we
would combine those two branches of
government in a motion of efficiency and
I would make Oliver North press
secretary because
he proved that you could lie with a
straight face and still get people to
donate money to the Contras name some
people who would have made great
presidents but never ran Marilyn Monroe
she made a great president see who else
and she never ran let me know senator
stood that the best people would never
think about running because it would be
totally insane and insane people can't
serve as president and what I mean it's
a prerequisite go go right down the list
so anyone said hello my name is Johnson
lift couple centuries ago democracy is
the worst form of government except for
all the rest now if we go beyond the
capitalism communism socialism you know
as economic models of government what
type of government would you like to
live under one which was able to
reconcile the differences between the
spiritual path and economic path
reconcile economic and spiritual and
individual freedom see that's the trick
of it you really like to outlaw apathy
but I don't think I can get enough
support for it
[Applause]
we'll continue with our Paul's time was
the 1960s when his unique political
journal the realist contains some of the
most advanced political satire and
comedy of the day Paul was also one of
the founders of the hippies an a narco
absurd this group that got national
attention in the 1960s well yuppies
became yuppies but Paul Krassner lives
on but before we talk with Paul here are
some news stories from the alternative
press well the information on the
history of the FBI's COINTELPRO program
and the attack on civil liberties by the
FBI so information continues to come out
and it's even more surprising North
Carolina lawyer and journalist Alexander
charns learned from a Freedom of
Information
documents that the FBI kept confidential
files on the Supreme Court from 1932 to
at least 1985 there was a over 2000
pages of files reveals that the FBI
wiretapped and monitored conversations
of the justices and that the court
employees were used as informants as
well documents show the Chief Justice
Earl Warren and Justice William Douglas
and a Fortas were specifically targeted
covertly because the they upheld the
rights of Communists according to the
FBI that during appeal in the Rosenberg
spy trial the chief of the Supreme
Court's security police
Philip crook reported information
overheard by his crew and he kept
special FBI agents advised of the
arrival and departure of key persons in
the case that's remarkable it's remember
the program we did with about Red Scare
the book Red Scare with Don Carlton the
author of Red Scare and he said that the
local red squads down in Houston and the
police department had we're keeping
dossiers not only on progressive or
liberal people like Barbara Jordan but
also on the mayor and other civic
leaders at the time incredible and yet
these FBI all these people are still
armed it's still doing their bit if you
could add one or two or three amendments
to the Constitution what would you want
three of them said the people shall
decide which drugs illegal or which are
illegal let's see what else in the
matter of abortion that life begins at
the moment of foreplay I would include
that dentists would have to experience
themselves whatever pain they gave you
in Palestinian perspective there is an
article by a woman who is a doctor from
England
she spent a lot of time in Lebanon and
in the occupied territories she has had
some very interesting insights she said
in summer of 82 when she was in the
refugee camps in Lebanon and in Sabra
and Shatila she said I discovered the
truth that Israel a country that I had
loved and respected all my life had
suddenly turned into a ruthless monster
she had treated some of the children
particularly who had been hit by some of
the weapons that the Israelis had had
she said the first child I treated was a
victim of a cluster bomb
thank God he died because if he lived he
too had no eyes no face no legs she
treated hundreds of thousands of
children in coming in equally as hurt
well then later she went to Gaza and
when she was in Gaza she was treating
Palestinians and she went to a prison
and noticed that in the Gaza Central
Jail the prisoners were put 25 to each
cell often having to sleep on top of
each other to be found with the
Palestinian flag to be suspected of
opposing the occupation by Israel would
earn long prison term every mine
throwing rocks at two Israelis the she
said that most of her patients had
either been beaten up by the army the
Israeli army or had been shot by them
the abbreviation be BA which means
beaten by the Army appeared regularly on
the medical records there are patients
with gunshot wounds Kurds in the
emergency room by terrified relatives
little children five six seven years of
age teenagers 13 12 years of age
occasionally the army just for a little
variety they would shoot kids shoot
around the kids instead of directly at
them and in their panic they would try
to climb over walls and then when they
got up on the top of the wall as the
army was
shooting around them then and then the
the kid get away from the shots there
they jump off the walls and when they
jumped off the walls then they would
break their legs and arms and then they
would come to her and she would try to
treat them and the Israelis would write
down fallen off the wall while trying to
escape from the Army
she said she treated Palestinians with
nasty high voltage burns sustained as a
result of being forced to take
Palestinian flags which had been put up
on electric poles they army had ordered
the Palestinians to remove the
Palestinian flag it ties in with
something in Harper's Magazine little
section called readings in which it was
reported people who saw Henry Kissinger
in a kind of a secret meeting with a
major American Jewish organization he
gave them advice on what Israel should
do and what they should do first of all
I said the Jews in the United States
should not criticize Israel but then he
said Israel should bar the media from
entry into the occupied territories and
then accept the short-term criticism of
the world press for doing that and then
to put down the insurrection as brutally
overwhelmingly and quickly as possible
then he said they they could ride out
the bad press for a while and it would
be all right that's Henry Kissinger's
formula for a lot of things and as Henry
Kissinger said power is the ultimate
aphrodisiac
I have another story on Kissinger and
his response to the brutal suppression
of the Chinese movement for democracy in
Tiananmen Square right after this brutal
suppression of shock the American people
in the entire world Kissinger was
constantly on American television saying
that he was a guest that Congress had
voted to impose sanctions against China
he was constantly saying we had to
accept the repression that we had to
understand Deng Xiaoping in the Chinese
government we had to keep our normalized
relations with China we couldn't risk
losing this special relation that was
developing and the Nation magazine
points out that at the same time that
Kissinger was making these statements on
behalf of the Chinese government he was
receiving fees in excess of two hundred
thousand dollars per year or per client
for advising such corporations as
shearson lehman hutton atlantic
richfield
HJ Heinz Union Carbide Chase Manhattan
Bank coca-cola and American Express each
one of these countries does a business
with China each one of them wants to
build more factories to do more business
and this requires good relationships
with the Chinese government so at the
same time that Kissinger is defending
the Chinese government for their
indefensible and brutal actions he's on
the payroll of all of these corporations
so the next time you see Kissinger on a
television spouting off something about
China
remember his own stake in u.s. Chinese
trade it's just disgraceful that the
corporate that the networks like Ted
Koppel on Nightline led him on so much
in these talk shows because he's a paid
operative of these big corporations who
has heavy interests in all the things
that he's making commentaries on what in
your opinion will best bring about peace
[Applause]
if we eliminate the bad guys
well wear of it in Texas would more kids
get beaten by the teachers and the
principal's and Dallas is right at the
heart of it there was a big article in
Dallas Times Herald which is very good
indicating that hundreds of more than
the $131,000 students get spanked every
day and according to Texas law they
don't even have to ask get the parents
consent before they start beating on the
kids now this is required and by the
policy of the Dallas Independent School
District as a matter of fact if some
principals don't report that they are
spanking kids and how many of them they
are they get into trouble as one
official said must be some difficulty
here I can't imagine them not having any
any problems with the kids down there
how come they're not whipping on your
own well the as I said the principals
and assistant principals can spank kids
even if their parents request they don't
children are not given a chance to tell
their side of the story there are no
guidelines on what kind of instruments
are to be administered whether to be
administered and with what type of
paddle or whatever but this practice is
very thoroughly entrenched in the Texas
schools only two school districts in the
whole state have banned corporal
punishment in 1987-1988 dollar schools
according to the Dallas Times Herald
reported six thousand two hundred and
seventy four paddling's and as the
superintendent for elementary education
warned the principal's that they
violated the Dallas Independent School
District policy if they don't beat their
kids well though there are some
organizations that are against this
corporal punishment against kids even
national organizations American Medical
the National PTA is against it the
American Bar Association is against it
not even to mention organizations like
American Civil Liberties Union
well the spanking of kids in Dallas I
kind of at the whim of the principal
some kids are only spanked for more
serious things like fighting but others
can be spanked for tardiness or for not
doing their homework the principles in
this principle say well there are some
kids that's that's all they respond to
because at home that's the principal
means of discipline and that's the only
thing they will they recognize that will
modify or change their behavior if
that's the only thing that happens at
home to try to modify behavior then
that's the only thing that kids will
respond to only two of the board members
of the school board in Dallas are
against this spanking one of the people
said who's against it said we're being
hypocrites in one essence we're telling
children not to be violent and
physically abuse each other and a
teacher and yet we're physically abusing
the kids and the Supreme Court in a
interesting decision said that it was
okay to beat kids in school there was a
case of two little girls I think they
were eight years old they were giggling
out in the hallway well the principal in
like that buying out on your giggling
they took him in they beat the little
girls and then sent it back to their
class and when they got in class they
got the giggles again and the teacher
spanked him well the portal's girls were
traumatized and then come back school
for another week or two
the parents took a tack or they were
also under doctors care parents took to
court and they lost the the trial court
held in favor of the parents and against
the school the appellate court ruled
against the school in favor of the
parents
the Supreme Court said you have go ahead
beat them kids
the Honorable Judge Paul Krassner has
been entrusted with making the
punishment fit the crime
that was one of my goals yeah
televangelists hmm and what's the crime
I have to test out what the punishment
is ruff to decide what the punishment of
the crime was I mean see there's a part
of the philosophical part of me that
believes that the crime and punishment
of the same process but you know you're
not going to stay a judge very long if
you know because you'll dismiss all your
cases that way so so you give me a
punishment I'll give you a crime and
I'll give you a punishment and if the
televangelists appeared before you oh ok
the band oh ok I would just well I'm I
guess I would have have them as
punishment have to watch their own
programs Tucson a tape loop you know
watch their pitches we will have Jean
Scott harangue himself for hours you
know just have jerry falwell talk about
the revelation and the beast you know
and had just happened tied to a chair
watching himself doing it I don't like
the force part of it but you know I'm
I'm a judge I can do whatever I want the
next case in front of your docket the
trans contractors defense contractors
and I would have them meet the families
of everybody who was ever injured by any
of the product that they manufactured
that would be that would be their
purgatory the director of the CIA I was
just bringing back to life that would be
enough punishment for him William
Rehnquist
I would just bring him back to life that
would be enough punishment but what
would be appropriate for William
Rehnquist I think that I would have stay
straight
do you know something about what goes on
under those gowns I would I would have
William Rehnquist be sentenced to forced
prayer at school you know I mean he
would have to pray we like forced busing
so that you would bring religious
students to non-religious schools back
and forth just for a balance of piety
and you just have to keep praying and
praying and praying I mean he could he
could pray for better decisions he would
have the freedom to pray for whatever he
wanted but but he would have to pray ed
Meese
ed Meese would have to give up prayer he
is really religious fanatic ed Meese
would have to be a clerk in an all-night
pornography store uh-huh Richard Nixon
he would have to be a customer in an
all-night pornography store
I am NOT a masturbator oh I love you
North what would he be I think I think
he would have to he would have to
whenever a football game was won or a
New Year's Eve was being celebrated he
would have to shred all the confetti the
people threw out windows calendars that
would be his job he would be the keeper
of the shredder he would have to shred
wheat you know whatever needed to be
shredded
that would be Ali's job the Pope the
Catholic Church it's you know well now
we have to deal with individuals here I
mean you can't condemn an institution
because an institution is you have to
take their leaders of the Pope
it's next I think the Pope would get a
job in a factory working with the people
on an assembly line you know a conveyor
belt his job would be to put condoms on
test tubes so that we could have
artificial sex but safe the Democratic
Party ah Democratic Party they would
have to unionize I think Democratic
Party I guess they would have to they
would have to face the ghosts of past
Democrats and explained to them what
they had allowed to happen to the party
and and to I guess they would have to
get into a session of maybe go to a
psychodrama and do role-playing and
pretend they were Republicans and see if
there was really any difference in the
way they acted the Republican Party I
think the Republican Party would have to
be homeless for six months of every year
we just have to live in the streets and
and then they probably would probably
check the voting pattern I would think
last and of course least everyone's
favorite lame guy
Ronald ray why would he make the
punishment said to cry oh my he would
have to do a press conference without
his hearing aid which is actually
getting the answers from his kitchen
cabinet and so he would have to wing it
he'd have to wing press conferences he
would have he would not get any
briefings he would have to explain
himself he would just have to and then
it would have to watch the rushes so
that he could see himself as others saw
him and he would have to expose the
strings you know - he's a marionette
that's not too well known which is why
he moves like that just the strings and
we would have to show who the marionette
operator was you know and it's a sort of
a a what they call of big things because
with a C not Lenny got arrested for but
it's wolf but but although they work in
these places they buy things cannot come
in diem come not condo
no but it's like that it's like that now
conundrums are prophylactics that you
can't quite quite get on you think is
the puppeteer well it varies you know
it's some some people from the Bechtel
corporation some people you know it's
it's from Oakland water from the liquor
industry lobby it's it's a court it's a
sort of a joint operation there but I
think it would be to expose the Wizard
of Oz based nature of the government you
know and so that just just pulling the
curtain from in front from behind Regan
who's manipulating the strings and then
I'd continue doing it you know I mean
but just let it be out front I would
like that
and and I would also like to put George
Bush in charge of selling clean urine to
basketball players well although it's
true that there's been a taboo on social
criticism and satire in the media to
some extent there's been something of a
rebirth of political humor since the
iran-contra affair began at least in the
cabaret level I was in Los Angeles this
spring and all of the comedy clubs were
having a great time with the iran-contra
hearings and more recently I saw on
television that in Washington DC there's
a lot of political cabarets that have
sprung out could have been having great
fun and you've been traveling around and
there was a political political humor
forum in Washington but they have people
like Mark Russell who is sort of the
poor person Steve Allen they have art
Brooke Walsh who has you know lunch with
Henry Kissinger I mean Mort saw now is
supporting Alexander Haig for the
presidency are you no no this is true in
fact it was Mort Sahl who gave Haig the
line I'm throwing my helmet into the
ring yeah but if you think about it more
saw has always gone with the power
structure you know even though he
supported John F Kennedy he also
supported the Bay of Pigs so you know he
he said he just became sort of a
latter-day Will Rogers but well yet at
the in the early 60s you know he would
take on Richard Nixon and he did a lot
of a sharp satire on that and that ilk
and then he fell into hard times and has
become rather bitter about it because a
lot of them so what happened is a lot of
a performance now well a lot of his
performances of is based on
name-dropping how he got invited to have
dinner with the Reagan's at the White
House and how all the Hollywood liberal
establishment like
Paul Newman and who else is a Hollywood
liberal establishment
Ed Asner yeah Jane Fonda they came to
him and said you know you should boycott
don't go to the dinner at the White
House and I personally thought you know
I felt that way but then part of me got
self-righteous because I thought well if
I got invited to the White House for
dinner would I go you know it would be
such a grist for my satirical mill and
to be on in the belly of the monster but
of course that's such a hypothetical
case that I can't even deal with this
well that's what Mort saw I saw the
thing on TV he was talking about this
very situation and he was saying well
after being spending the evening there
with Reagan that he realizes that Darwin
Darwin's theory was blown out of the
water survival of the fittest hasn't
occurred in Reagan's case well except
that Reagan is about to reveal that it
was Bonzo who first told him about the
theory of creationism
this is the reconciliation between those
two sure wasn't Bonzo who started the
AIDS it wasn't monkey in Africa when
Palin got started oh I'll tell you it's
I saw in the airport Lyndon LaRouche
people with signs that said mosquitoes
don't wear condoms yeah and at first I
didn't understand I thought he was
talking about the mosquitos in Nicaragua
the tribes but he was talking about aids
and how in Africa and Florida there are
mosquitoes it actually can transmit the
AIDS virus
so I had to assure him that it was only
if they shared their needles what
inspired you to start doing what you're
doing
were you got an itch you scratch it
it's just it was just a survival for me
you know I mean people wake up to the
fact that they're martians at different
times in life I woke up to it early and
I realized that I would have to learn to
pass as an earthling if I wanted to
survive
and so I use humor as as my vehicle
because it was because laughter is what
I imprinted on in terms of you know
waking up to the mystery of your own
existence everybody has that and some
people go back to sleep because the
world is just too painful to bear and so
you need to imprint on something to deal
with all the pain and horror that there
is in the world to allow you to you know
to focus on some of the beauty and the
pleasure too and if you want to be a
real rounded person and so it Jets so
for me
humor became my religion in effect I
mean it's just my way of perceiving the
world I mean yeah everybody has to have
a metaphor for the mystery okay I mean
cuz life is a mystery if it's not a
mystery what the [ __ ] isn't that's my
philosophy so what you what do you see
your role is being I guess I'm sort of
court jester of the revolution or maybe
poppyseed I'm not sure car choosing
roles well of all the sages and
philosophers may be a sage role that
would be good oh I'm just gonna say many
of the sages of philosophers seem to be
political satirist who's your favorite
and more well Lenny Bruce was the one
who influenced me the most because he he
went all the way you know he just he he
balanced on the edge and then he
realized that the edge was infinite and
so even though he's dead you know I
still relate to him as a touchstone for
the the tradition that I'm trying to
carry on that he was part of where's
some of the other major warts all dead -
I mean you know he may he may be bitter
now but you know he was a pioneer
[Music]
Richard Pryor Lily Tomlin there are you
know I'm influenced as a female Lenny
Bruce set
that's what he said actually have a bad
crop that he said two things that were
one was that I am part of everything I
indict which I think is important
because we all have a little out of a
North in us but he he was he said I am
influenced by every waking moment of my
life and so so you know the the people
whose humor I I admire can come from
anywhere I heard about a ghetto kid in
Austin seven years old who when he saw
the photograph of Michael Jackson in
this health chamber of some sort that
that he wanted to rejuvenate himself and
if he ever got old and this kid just
effortless the effortlessly said he's
just trying to freeze-dry his aides as a
seven-year-old ghetto kid you know think
of the cynicism and the sophistication
that come that comes from that Johnny
Carson's writers who get $5,000 a week
to write jokes about unemployment well
you know would be hard-pressed to come
up with those kind of cultural
connections so that so there's a weird
Asst that kids have today that that they
didn't have when I was a kid but it also
points to your theory of humor as being
a self-protective mechanism you take the
things that are most frightening and
most threatening like aids or
iran-contra or Oliver North or nuclear
weapons and you somehow turn your fear
into you and you overcome your fear
that's why I was so influenced by the
seven-year-old kid I mean I heard this a
couple of days ago and I just been
thinking about it the implications of it
because it also means it's a way of the
kids saying one of my interpretations of
it is that that it's a way of the of the
kid dealing with being a ghetto kid by
saying you know even Michael Jackson
can't protect himself from that kind of
fate if that's what his fate is right
Paul you also wrote from Mad Magazine
and wrote for Steve Allen did you write
for Steve Allen first when he was on TV
or that this was a freelance basis the
old
in the when he had his show on I did a
couple of sketches I did a song that I
wrote he put the music to called
cosa nostra it was a romantic ballad our
thing headlines about I give you the
kiss of death and yeah and out Steve
Allen has always been he has a Malins I
don't know of how many hundreds of
people that he sends articles to Xeroxes
of articles that have interested him you
know about whether it's mafia influence
in the Teamsters or teamster influence
in the Mafia
he's although he's kind of now he's
doing some kind of bran flakes
commercial but you know I guess it I
guess it comes out one way or the other
if you could give America the good news
bad news what would it be well that the
the bulletin of Atomic Scientists
periodically publishes on their cover
o'clock showing how many minutes we are
to midnight midnight representing total
nuclear disaster and recently they moved
it up from four minutes to midnight to
three minutes to midnight now I'm not
sure what their time scale is whether a
minute represents a month or a year or a
decade but whatever it is we are now
three minutes to total nuclear holocaust
so I would say that's the bad news
the good news is that atomic scientists
are just as neurotic as the rest of us
they set their clocks 15 minutes ahead
so the good news is really 18 minutes to
total nuclear doomsday we have that
extra time to fool around them what
would you say has been the greatest
political prank ever played and besides
maybe the election of Ronald Reagan six
years after we turn Nixon out I mean
yeah there there has to be some other
right the greatest political prank ever
played well I guess the debate pigs
might fit into that category
you know and I suppose if Kennedy had
gotten air cover from the CIA that would
have transformed it from the prank
category to the hoax category well I
guess I guess the notion that Democrats
and Republicans are really that
different I think is probably the
greatest political prank you know the
the illusion of a two-party system when
it's really several parties you know the
Lockheed Christmas party the Northrop
Christmas party a lot of it's a multiple
party system and when did you begin the
realist it was 1958 what led you to do
this at the end of the McCarthy period
now it was the McCarthy period it was
the frustration at Mad in that they
would they didn't won anything that
wasn't for teenagers I wanted to do
something on unions in fact and I said
no it's too adult just a subject matter
they wouldn't even look at it I did the
first thing I saw too mad was a thing
called if comic strip characters
answered those little ads in the back of
magazines and I would just write the
script and it would it was illustrated
by while he would the late Wally Wood
who did the Disneyland and memorial orgy
in the realist when Disney died I just
said just just let your imagination flow
and show us what would have happened now
that these people who no longer have the
restraints that Disney put on them you
know what would these characters do and
so you had goofy and Minnie Mouse
humping on a cash register at Disneyland
while Mickey Mouse was shooting up and
Dumbo was defecating on Donald Duck
screaming back at him and Tinker Bell
was doing the striptease for a bunch of
people and Pinocchio's nose got longer
as he watched sort of displaced arousal
but there but in this article I did
format on the part on the things of
comic strip characters would answer the
little ads we had like Little Orphan
Annie and
he had from Maybelline so she could get
some makeup on her blank eyes and Ali
you care getting rid of his superfluous
hair and one of the things was olive oil
sending away for falsies because she was
very flat-chested objectively speaking
and they didn't want to run that they
thought it was funny but Bill Gaines the
publisher said to me look you know I
know my mother will object to that and I
said yeah he was 35 years old at the
time I said yeah but you know she's not
a typical reader of mad and he said no
but she's a typical mother and so there
was that thing you know we you you want
to rock the boat but you know within
limits within the limits yeah you wanted
to go over the limits I didn't want to
think about limits I just wanted to I
mean I have my own limits I mean because
I have paradoxes on one hand
irreverence is my only social cow my so
my only sacred cow on the other hand I
don't want the victims to be the target
of my humor so even though I'll talk
about aids of somebody who is suffering
from AIDS is not the target of my humor
the target of my humor is my own fears
and inhibitions and hypocrisy and by
extension those of the audience the
other paradox is that in my own Zen
bastard spiritual quest I try not to
judge people which is pretty bizarre for
a social critic but it's a challenge
because it one form of satire is to see
things from the point of view of the
executioner you know because they they
as I said before they have their own
logic and I think the most outrageous
thing I ever saw any comedic performance
stage was when many Bruce took things
from the point of view of Adolf Eichmann
sympathetically you know trying to say
well I went to the ovens every day and I
look through the porthole I saw I had
done my job well that day and I went
back home now he didn't get many laughs
bring this but he did it in a nightclub
to an audience which probably had a lot
of Jews in it and and I asked him about
this later because when I first
interviewed Lenny he said the the
function of a comedian is to get a laugh
every 15 to 25 second I'm he was very
precise about it and now who sometimes
go off rambling you know and talk about
his court cases and because he always
talked about his environment now his
environment just happened to be paddy
wagons and courtrooms more and more and
I said you're not getting those left's
every 15 to 25 seconds now Lenny he says
well they said that was my definition of
a comedian I'm not a comedian I'm
changing I said what do you mean he said
well I'm not a comedian I'm Lenny Bruce
so he saw himself as a symbolic that he
had assumed a function in society it
wasn't just that he was a comic anymore
he knew that he had become a symbol
because he in fact his FBI I got his FBI
files
I got Helen Keller's FBI files - that's
right she was a socialist well in fact
there was a great thing
J Edgar Hoover said that they should
keep files on her in fact he refused to
because she got a birthday card from
Helen Gurley Brown
she sent a birthday card the Helen
Gurley Brown when she was in prison at
the age of 65 so obviously Helen Keller
deaf dumb and blind was it was a
dangerous subversive had early Brown was
the wobbly one from the IWW right I
thought she was the editor of
Cosmopolitan oh okay no I don't kind of
year-old Alyssa I really feel in maybe
okay I've got IW you know that's yeah
let's that's the problem with today's
mixed-up world when you mix up the
Wobblies with cosmopolitan that yourself
is the kind of political satire I know I
know that well that's the thing that the
attention span it's so quick quick quick
that people here Abbie Hoffman now say
isn't she the state senator from
Arkansas
you know it's Amy Carter I think she's
with a new pump group isn't she I mean
people really forget and yet the fact
that Abbie Hoffman and Amy Carter were
co-defendants in that CIA recruiting
suit
which they want I went to the victory
party and it was very significant
because Lenny wineglass the attorney for
the case we asked him what do you think
was a turning point in the jury's
consciousness because that's at a great
precedent and he said well it was when
Ralph McGehee testified the former
football player who was recruited by the
CIA right off the playing field and
ended up in their assassination squads
and they made the point that in the 60s
they would not have been able to use
this necessity defense because the jury
wouldn't have believed that the CIA did
things like that but they become jaded
and sophisticated enough that they were
prepared to believe that kind of
testimony under what john stockwell
former CIA person who wrote in search of
enemies had to say he would write stuff
and the editors of the book who were
looking at it before it was published
I'd say we can't publish this nobody
believed it and Stocking to say but it's
real it's what really happened they said
no nobody believed it yeah I know when I
in the realist I published work by Maebh
Russell who was a conspiracy researcher
from Carmel California and this and she
an article called why was Martha
Mitchell kidnapped she delineating the
conspiracy behind the Watergate break-in
which was still being called by the
mainstream press a caper a third-rate
burglary and she named Nixon and L
Patrick gray and John Mitchell because
she had been doing research into the
Kennedy assassination since 63 so she
saw the same personnel involved she saw
the same modus operandi and this was
nine months before the it actually came
out in the mainstream press and so
people then were telling me you're crazy
they were not prepared to believe it you
know when the truth came out I felt
vindicated and you know they say well
you know you were crazy but you were
right it's probably the same thing with
these drugs today the theories of the
Contras being drug runners a lot of
people probably just don't believe this
at all and then eventually the
information will come out and the
critics would like the Christic
Institute and yourself and alternative
views will be vindicated well but it's
not the key is it's not just the Contras
doing it on their
they're doing it in a relationship with
the CIA yeah
and they even the George Bush's office
uh-huh oh yeah yeah George Bush we're
really waiting to come out from behind
the bush I mean there is a theory that
he was the one who gave the go-ahead on
the LaPenta bombing this is where Eden
Pastore was going to hold the press
conference and it gets confusing to
people because they say well why would
they want to get rid of him be any
ethics lingual see he was not he was a
contra but he wasn't one of our Contras
he was not unifying with the other
groups you know he wasn't he wasn't
following the CIA's orders Paul during
the Watergate here you had a lot of fun
satirizing the Nixon administration how
do you see comparisons between the
iran-contra scandals and hearings and
the Watergate affair and hearings and
also from the standpoint of humor what
are the differences that it presents for
satirical targeting uh-huh well this
came out there was a humor conference in
international human conference and there
were five delegates from Russia and they
asked an American performer like me it
was kind of interesting thing for me as
a editor of an American satirical
magazine to meet the editor of crocodile
which is this Russian satirical magazine
but supported by the state there so they
have a lot of humor about absenteeism
and productivity and as one of the
former editor there who edited the book
of Russian underground humor told me he
said that the humor in crocodile is for
the state it's not for the people and so
I was one of a few people invited to try
and make these Russians laugh and I
tried to pick something that would
demonstrate freedom of expression in
this country you know again that paradox
that we have you know that political
candidates have gotten into office by
dint of assassinations that then made it
look like they were brought in by a
mandate and yet we have the freedom
under the First Amendment to talk about
how rotten we are so I try to so the
story I told was in answer to your
question was comparing the
Watergate scandal than the Contra gate
and there of course we had the smoking
gun we had the 80 and a half minutes
missing from Nixon's tape which of
course general Haig referred to as being
caused by sinister forces I tell you
it's a bunch of nuts around that White
House and so screwed up I've lost a nut
vote now more politics so where we have
comparable to that you know in Iran gate
we had only the brain surgery on William
Casey where they removed the section
from August 1985 to November 1986 so you
know that I began to get suspicious it
and so as I told that story there it was
translated you know I would pause and
then the American audience would laugh
and then it would be translated and the
Russians would laugh and so you know
they both laughed at that so it was kind
of a kind of unifying humor the and of
course now you know just the notion of
obviously Casey is going to become the
scapegoat because dead men don't talk
and Poindexter will testify that he
reported to Casey and so we'll never
know if Casey reported to Reagan so it's
a it's a very convenient death you know
and I suspect that soon the Ali and 88
buttons will be replaced by who killed
Casey buttons
the most former fascism I saw longboards
yeah
is not that is it then a machine not so
very sunny and was the changes our
nervous system if you hear it won't
happen you hear something on TV that you
think is funny that there's no laughter
and we find some way the [ __ ] setting
for that sound collision and so in
effect also for our new show
and he asked this question what was the
I have to say Don vibrators
[Applause]
seriously
he has
sorry
then I saw Lina here in 0-7 Gemma said
yes your question he said name one or
two or three people in America today
that are relevant people can learn from
anybody they meet you know everybody
meet is relevant you can learn from
what's Paul crassness next goal uh-huh
what's my next goal to be a champion
hockey player let's go uh or maybe a
circus giant I can't decide maybe should
take a vocational aptitude test
um I mean there's projects you know I
want to I want to continue editing the
realist and performing and do freelance
writing but there's a couple of books a
few books I want to put together one's a
collection of pieces that I've done it
would either be called murder at the
humor convention or I snorted cocaine
with the Pope me once the kind of classy
title the others a little bit more
commercial the and then as another is an
autobiography which is unauthorized
I'm writing it against my better
judgment and then the other is a novel
based on a controversial comedian that
was inspired by Lenny so you know that's
Darris are there projects that I wonder
but there are so many unknowns you know
that you really I really I guess my
chief goal is to act as if process
itself were my goal and then and then it
saves a lot of disappointment you know
if you get hit by the bus just before
your book comes out